the wild and very emotional day in kyle
rittenhouse's murder trial the 18 year
old yesterday told the court that he
killed two people in kenosha wisconsin
during a black lives matter protest in
self-defense
during his testimony rittenhouse broke
down in
tears he was sobbing on the stand the
prosecutors questioned him aggressively
at one point during a stern rebuke from
the judge and a request for a mistrial
from rittenhouse's lawyer nancy chen is
outside the courthouse in kenosha
yesterday nancy i watched in real time
it was riveting yesterday good morning
to you
good morning to you gail yes it was
riveting and yesterday was the first
time jurors heard from kyle written how
some appearing sympathetic as he broke
down on the stand greenhouse testified
for several hours telling the court he
felt he had no choice but to fight for
his life
there were
three
people right there
kyle radenhouse broke down on the stand
wednesday shortly after he started to
detail his encounter with joseph
rosenbaum one of the two men he shot and
killed august 25 2020.
that's right
the judge paused the trial to allow
rittenhouse to collect himself his
mother watched in tears
leo written house defended his actions
saying he shot rosenbaum about four
times the person that attacked me first
threatened to kill me whitehouse says he
then tried to get to the police as
protesters began to chase him why were
you trying to get to the police i didn't
do anything wrong i defended myself
rittenhouse says as he was trying to get
away the second man he shot and killed
anthony huber hit him with a skateboard
and tried to take his weapon he grabs my
gun and i can feel it pulling away from
me and this i can feel the strap
starting to come off my my body and what
do you do then i fire one shot rinhaus
says he shot a third man gage
grosskroitz the only surviving victim
because gross kroitz had a pistol and
was standing over him i was never trying
to kill the defendant you intentionally
use deadly force against anthony huber
correct
you intentionally use deadly force
against gauge gross courts correct yes
with regard to joseph rosenbaum you
fired four shots at him correct yes on
cross-examination prosecutor thomas
binger tried to paint rittenhouse as the
armed instigator mr rittenhouse you're
telling us
that you felt
like you were about to die right
yes but when you point the gun at
someone else that's going to make them
feel like they're about to die right
that's what you wanted him to feel no
don't get brazen with me when it was the
prosecution's turn to question written
house the judge interrupted several
times calling out the prosecutor for
questioning rittenhouse's silence after
his arrest and attempting to bring in
evidence the judge had previously ruled
inadmissible when you say that you were
acting in good faith i don't believe
that after the exchange the defense
sought a mistrial but with prejudice
meaning written house would go free and
could not be retried for the shootings
cbs news legal analyst ricky clement
what the defense suggests is that the
prosecution
knowing it was losing was actually
purposefully
doing misconduct so that it would cause
its own mistrial in order to get another
crack at the case
but all in all the prosecution at this
level of experience should know better
than to do either of the two things that
it did
the judge was not willing to rule on
whether he would grant a mistrial yet
but if this trial does continue the jury
would likely get the case early next
week and if convicted of homicide
rittenhouse could face life in prison
nate
gayle said it best riveting testimony
nancy thank you